en este vídeo vamos a hablar acerca del
mercado de manzanas y entonces nos vamos
a fijar acerca de la curva de la demanda
y es la curva de la oferta en esta
ocasión me voy a fijar en ambas curvas
por lo tanto vamos a dibujar nuestros
ejes este va a ser el eje del precio que
por cierto está dado en pesos por
kilogramo y del otro lado voy a hablar
de la cantidad y la cantidad va a estar
dada en miles de kilogramos así que
vamos a poner algunas marquitas voy a
poner que aquí es un peso por kilogramo
aquí va a ser dos pesos por kilogramo
tres pesos por kilogramo cuatro pesos y
cinco pesos por kilogramo ojo la
cantidad está dada en miles de
kilogramos y también es necesario tomar
un periodo de tiempo por lo tanto vamos
a decir que son miles de kilogramos por
una semana y aquí los voy a poner tengo
mil kilogramos dos mil kilogramos tres
mil kilogramos cuatro mil y cinco mil
kilogramos y bueno ahora vamos a pensar
en las dos curvas tanto en la curva de
la demanda como en la curva de la oferta
entonces lo primero que voy a ver es la
curva de la demanda y bueno para
graficar la curva de la demanda
voy a preguntar es qué pasa si yo elevó
mucho mi precio de mis manzanas y bueno
pues la respuesta es sencilla si yo
tengo un precio muy alto por lo tanto
voy a vender muy poco porque realmente
muy poca gente va a querer comprar mis
manzanas por lo tanto vamos a suponer
que si yo le doy el precio de cinco
pesos por kilogramo se beben en 500
kilogramos solamente 500 kilogramos y es
este punto que tengo aquí ojos se me
vende la cantidad de 500 kilogramos no
es la demanda cuando yo pienso en la
demanda estoy pensando en la relación
entera es decir los 500 kilogramos de
manzana con el precio de 5 pesos por
kilogramo y bueno ahora vamos a fijar el
segundo punto vamos a decir que cuando
yo tengo un precio de un peso por
kilogramos vendo 4 mil kilogramos de
manzana por lo tanto la demanda es
cuatro mil kilogramos que se venden a un
peso por kilogramo y bueno esta curva no
me gustó entonces mejor voy a hacer otra
uniendo los dos puntos que ya tenemos
vamos a escribir la curva de la demanda
y ahora voy a pensar en la curva de la
oferta y bueno vamos a suponer
inicialmente que para empezar a producir
manzanas yo necesito un costo de 50
centavos por manzana entonces lo voy a
poner
tengo un costo inicial para empezar a
producir manzanas de 50 centavos ahora
viene el segundo punto que me voy a
tomar para dibujar esta curva de la
oferta va a ser este de aquí voy a decir
que producir mil kilogramos de manzana
tiene un costo de un peso y bueno aquí
está ya mi curva de la oferta y cuando
digo esto no estoy pensando solamente
nosotros estoy pensando en todos los
operadores que hay pues si yo quisiera
podría pensar esta curva para un solo
oferta d'or o solamente para un mercado
o solamente para un tipo de manzana y en
este caso estoy hablando para todos los
tipos de mercados y de manzanas que hay
y bueno ahora ha llegado el momento de
pensar en los distintos escenarios que
puede haber el primer escenario que les
quiero plantear es qué pasa si todos los
productores por alguna razón la verdad
no sé cuál pero supongamos que todos los
productores toman la decisión de que van
a vender por estas semanas las manzanas
al precio de un peso por kilogramo
entonces estamos aquí y de hecho se dan
cuenta cuando nosotros hablábamos de que
las manzanas se venden en un peso por
kilogramo dada la curva de la oferta la
cantidad de manzanas que pueden producir
solamente son 1000
no pueden producir más porque esto es lo
que nos marca la curva de la oferta y es
que este dato es muy importante por lo
tanto lo voy a escribir aquí de color
rosa voy a agarrar el color rosado para
escribir esto que acabo de decir qué
quiere decir esto que la cantidad que
vamos a producir cuando tenemos el
precio de un peso es de 1000 kilogramos
y ahora sería bueno preguntarnos cuál es
la cantidad que nosotros tenemos en la
demanda y bueno recuerden que este es
nuestro primer escenario en el cual
tenemos un precio y este precio era
inicial y era de un peso por kilogramo
entonces lo voy a poner aquí el precio
de un peso por kilogramo ahora bien si
regresamos a la pregunta acerca de cuál
es la cantidad de la demanda y nos
fijamos en la gráfica nos vamos a dar
cuenta que lo que nos piden son 4000
kilogramos y qué es lo que pasa en este
caso a pues que tenemos un cierto
déficit y de hecho este déficit es la
diferencia entre 4.000 y 1000 que son
3.000 kilogramos de manzanas tenemos un
déficit de 3 mil kilogramos de manzanas
y eso qué implica
bueno si nos fijamos en el siguiente
periodo de tiempo que es lo que va a
pasar
bueno pues veámoslo así lo primero que
va a pasar es que el precio va a
aumentar como son tantas personas las
que necesitan manzanas y tan poquitas
manzanas entonces la gente va a querer
pagar más por las manzanas para obtener
las manzanas que necesitan entonces lo
primero que quiero que veamos es que el
precio va a aumentar por lo tanto lo voy
a escribir aquí el precio aumenta y
además de que el precio va a aumentar lo
siguiente que va a pasar es que los
productores se van a dar cuenta de que
hay una gran cantidad de demanda de
manzanas y por lo tanto se les va a
ocurrir producir más manzanas puedes
producir más manzanas ellos van a
conseguir que la gente compre sus
manzanas por lo tanto van a aumentar la
cantidad de producción es decir que en
el siguiente periodo de tiempo en este
caso en la siguiente semana porque
estábamos hablando de semanas lo que va
a pasar es que nos vamos a mover sobre
esta curva va a aumentar el precio de
las manzanas y va a aumentar también la
producción de manzanas y por lo tanto
vamos a suponer que en la siguiente
semana vamos a vender a un precio de 2
pesos por kilogramo y por lo tanto se
venden cerca de dos mil kilogramos son
supongamos 1900 kilogramos
y ahora si observamos la gráfica lo que
va a pasar es que el déficit disminuye
es decir tenemos una cantidad menor de
déficit y creo que ya con esto ustedes
se dan una idea hacia dónde vamos pero
bueno antes de llegar al punto donde nos
interesa quiero que veamos otra
situación y yo sé que ustedes están muy
interesados en qué es lo que va a
suceder justo en este punto pero antes
de llegar a ese punto vamos a subir
mucho el precio supongamos que la
siguiente semana estamos tan contentos
porque nos piden tantas manzanas que se
nos ocurre subir el precio hasta tres
pesos por kilogramo estamos tan felices
por la demanda que hemos tenido con
nuestras manzanas que decidimos subir
demasiado el precio y llegamos hasta
tres pesos por kilogramo si nos fijamos
en la curva de la oferta que es lo que
va a pasar bueno nosotros tenemos una
cantidad de producción de 3.000
kilogramos de manzanas por lo tanto
estamos en este caso y lo voy a escribir
aquí el precio es de 3 pesos por
kilogramo y qué cantidad tenemos en
nuestra curva de oferta nosotros vamos a
tener una cantidad de producción de 3
kilogramos cantidad de producción de
3.000 kilogramos que es esta que tenemos
aquí muy bien 3.000 kilogramos ahora qué
es lo que va a pasar con la cantidad de
la demanda también nos importa saber
cuál es la cantidad de la demanda en
este precio y sin embargo la cantidad de
la demanda va a bajar porque está tan
cada la manzana que entonces muchas
personas van a decidir comprar no sé
pedazos plátanos o cualquier otra fruta
porque se le va a ser excesivo el precio
de la manzana y por lo tanto vamos a
suponer que la cantidad de la demanda es
como 1300 entonces voy a poner cantidad
de la demanda son 1.300 kilogramos y
bueno ahora qué es lo que va a pasar en
este escenario nosotros tendremos mayor
cantidad de oferta que de demanda y por
lo tanto vamos a tener un excedente este
va a ser nuestro excedente que también
va a ser la diferencia y mejor lo voy a
escribir de esta manera porque estamos
en el mismo escenario el excedente va a
ser pues la diferencia entre 3000 menos
1300 que son como 1.700 kilogramos y
bueno una vez que ya tenemos este
excedente que es lo que va a pasar pues
como no hay tanta demanda
de manzanas pues el precio está muy
elevado entonces los productores se
empiezan a preocupar se empiezan a poner
nerviosos y lo que van a hacer es bajar
el precio para que se vendan sus
manzanas y además de que están bajando
el precio como se están dando cuenta que
no toda la gente está comprando manzanas
van a tener que bajar la cantidad de
producción por lo tanto en la cantidad
de producción también va a disminuir
cantidad de producción va a disminuir
también es decir que no estamos moviendo
bajo la curva de la oferta de esta
manera nos estamos moviendo hacia abajo
y por lo tanto vamos también a este
punto de equilibrio en este caso estamos
disminuyendo el precio y también estamos
disminuyendo la cantidad de producción y
por mientras en la curva de la demanda
lo que va a pasar es que como está
disminuyendo el precio entonces va a
aumentar la demanda en la curva de
oferta bajamos el precio y por lo tanto
también bajamos la cantidad y por lo
tanto en la curva de la demanda va a
aumentar también y también es lo mismo
para el caso anterior si nosotros
aumentamos el precio y entonces subimos
en la curva de la oferta lo que va a
pasar es que la demanda va a disminuir
porque estamos aumentando el precio
es decir cada vez va a haber menos gente
que quería comprar manzanas porque el
precio es aumentando y se dan cuenta
todo converge a este punto que tenemos
aquí este es el punto importante de este
vídeo en el cual se intersectan las dos
curvas la curva de la oferta y la curva
de la demanda o dicho de otra manera en
este punto la cantidad de manzanas que
tenemos en la oferta es la misma
cantidad de manzanas que tenemos en la
demanda y vamos a suponer que este
precio en este caso particular es como
de 2 pesos con 15 centavos y le vamos a
llamar el precio de equilibrio de hecho
este es el punto de equilibrio entonces
voy a escribir aquí el precio de
equilibrio que tenemos en el punto de
equilibrio que por cierto habíamos
acordado que es de 2 pesos con 15
centavos por kilogramo y bueno ya
tenemos el precio de equilibrio vamos a
sacar también la cantidad de equilibrio
que es esta que está aquí que son como 2
mil 200 kilogramos entonces vamos a
escribirlo la cantidad de equilibrio y
de hecho es la cantidad de equilibrio
aquí donde tenemos que fijar
en la cantidad de demanda ni en la
cantidad de oferta porque son iguales y
es de 2.200 kilogramos 2.200 kilogramos
y si asumimos que no nos falta nada este
es un buen escenario para ambas partes
tanto los consumidores y los productores
todos están contentos todas las manzanas
se venden y nada parece estar mal